[Musique]
alexis merci d'être avec nous la rentrée
sociale s'annonce tendue pour le
gouvernement n'a déjà une date le 5
octobre il faut pas sortir dans paris
surtout pas des chats est ce que ce
gouvernement est ce qu'il veut jouer le
jeu du dialogue social selon vont oui
alors il est obligé déjà d'une d'une
part ensuite effectivement il ya une
côte et jouer le dialogue social et puis
avoir un vrai dialogue parce qu'on voit
qu'il ya un empressement de la part du
gouvernement de remettre sur la table la
réforme des retraites inquiété tout
arrêté par la crise du coc vide ne
remettre sur la table également la
réforme de l'allocation de l'assurance
chômage qui avait été retoqué par le
conseil d'état est là les partenaires
sociaux voient bien cet empressement ils
se disent que cette crise sanitaire qui
a permis de temporiser là où le
gouvernement voulait passer par la force
veulent retrouver le dialogue renouer le
dialogue sur ces sujets là bien sûr et
puis d'autres sujets qui posent question
le pass sanitaire qui est en train de
chambouler complètement le droit du
travail avec un flou artistique à
hauteur de la suspension d'activité si
pas de passes sanitaire est là les
syndicats demandent davantage de clarté
à la ministre elisabeth baume bien
entendu mais aussi au premier ministre
qui eux ont bien du mal à expliquer et
puis il ya un troisième volet plus
compliqué celui là c'est la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte des entreprises qui ont
été tenus à bout de bras avec des
implants dead qui a coûté 80 milliards
d'euros de subventions et 160 milliard
d'euros de prêts nous dit bruno le maire
mais combien d'entreprises qui ne vont
pas pouvoir passer l'année 2021 2022 qui
vont mettre la clé sous la porte ne pas
rembourser le prêt d'un côté ou bien ne
pas pouvoir continuer leurs activités
vous en parlez avec 6 à la mobilisation
qui passe
s'ajoutent donc les revendications
sociales est ce que ça peut trouver
justement un écho amplifié
bien oui on voit que depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines au coeur de l'été
chaque samedi on a retrouvé ces
mobilisations qu'on connaissait lors du
mouvement gilet jaune beaucoup plus
hétéroclites encore une fois avec des
familles des gens qui manifestent pour
la première fois trans partisan encore
une fois contre se passe sanitaires bien
entendu qui rompt la promesse d'égalité
de la république française et puis
derrière il faut voir aussi l'état du
pays avec une consommation des ménages
qui a de nouveau baissé en juillet de -2
2% un marasme économique car les
restaurateurs qui ont dit que l'arrivée
du passani terre en août n'a pas aidé
leur saison et puis des destructions
d'emplois plus de 60 une suppression
d'emplois déjà et d'autres qui sont dans
les tuyaux avec en plus un pouvoir
d'achat qui baisse le coût de la vie ne
fait qu'augmenter que ce soit l'énergie
le prix de l'essence qui est au plus
haut bien plus haut que lors de la crise
des gilet jaune et les salaires qui
n'augmentent pas puisque bruno le maire
nous dit que nous n'allons pas augmenter
les minima sociaux ni le smic ni quoi
quoi d'autre alors qu'il demande au
patron de faire un effort mais c'est
difficile si l'économie n'est pas au
rendez-vous la croissance n'est pas au
rendez vous donc on voit bien que tout
est fait pour qu'il y ait une rentrée
sociale explosive
au delà même de la date du 5 octobre
puisque les mouvements anti passe
n'attendent pas les demandes syndicales
pour descendre dans la rue pendant ce
temps les maquereaux lui va sur le
terrain il a choisi marseille pour sa
rentrée politique c'est un choix qui
vous surprend non c'est un choix je
pense extrêmement calculé pourquoi
marseille alors d'abord cette ville est
en proie à une violence une insécurité
grandissante avec des règlements de
compte qui endeuille la ville mais le
volet sécuritaire encore une fois va
être un peu cachée mais vaincre on
préfère ne pas trop la bordée le maire
demande et 900 forces de police
supplémentaires il y en aura trois cents
finalement emmanuel macron y va pour la
rénovation urbaine les transports les
écoles aussi grand chantier marseillais
1,2 milliard promis pour la rénovation
des écoles qu'est ce qu'il fait mal elle
macron il est en campagne alors il sort
le carnet de chèques rien de nouveau
sous le soleil c'est ce qu'avait fait
manuel valls avant de quitter matignon
legrand prend plan banlieue de l'époque
a été enterré dans les cartons une fois
les élections passées ça pourrait être à
peu près la même chose alors sans doute
non mais c'est quand même assez
cocasse de voir le chef de l'état
central aller auprès d'une ville qui
dépend aussi d'une région qui sont
paupérisée défavorisées puisque régions
plus pauvres par rapport aux mesures
décentralisation promu par emmanuel
macron donc on est là dans une mise en
scène encore une fois où il se donne le
beau rôle celui du sauveur alors qu'en
réalité il n'a rien n'est rien fait pour
aider sur le terrain et que les
marseillais n'ont pas attendu emmanuel
macron pour rénover les écoles on se
rappelle de de ces rénovations faites
par les parents d'élèves il ya de ça
quelques mois et donc il ya aussi un peu
un côté assez
indigne je pense d'arriver à marseille
au moment où le professeur raoul est mis
à terre tel un césar arrivant après la
mise à mort devait singes et oryx en
disant ça y est je suis venu j'ai vaincu
sans même combattre d'ailleurs en tout
cas ouvert à l'accueil comment lui est
réservé les marseillais emmanuel macron
merci elle décrit d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir